un dernier au revoir
dans ce lieu symbolique emblème de la
démocratie au canada pour le doyen du
parlement le bloquiste louis plamondon
c'est aussi un deuxième chez-soi il y
est entré pour la première fois en 1984
comme député conservateur et il a été
élu sans interruption depuis c'est
devenu ma deuxième maison un bus a
tellement de mal aujourd'hui à 75 ans il
arpente les couloirs de l'édifice
central du parlement pour l'une des
dernières fois avant sa fermeture
là on entre dans la bibliothèque sauce
bonlieu de flânage tout en bois comme ce
ça marche chaleureux comme comme
l'édifice reconstruit presque
entièrement après l'incendié de 1916 a
besoin d'une cure de rajeunissement
il faut enlever l'amiante des murs
changer les tuyaux remplacer le système
électrique et solidifier sa structure
des travaux qui prendront au moins dix
ans ça prend beaucoup de mélancolie
parce que c'est un endroit qu'on n'a pas
à aimer milk est beau à compter
d'aujourd'hui le compte à rebours
commence il faut tout déménagé pour que
la nouvelle chambre soit prête au retour
des fêtes
le plus gros défi gérer c'est vraiment
le temps qu'il nous reste à peu près six
semaines avant que la chambre sièges
il y encore de la planification à faire
toutes les bureaux des députés
il faut qu'ils emballent toutes leurs
effets personnels
c'est le président de la chambre qui
doit s'assurer que le déménagement se
façon demain on a des choses assez
spécial même les pupitres de dans la
chambre qui doivent être déménagées sont
importants dans notre histoire
mais au delà d'être responsable du bon
déroulement jefferies guen voit
également son rôle comme celui de
gardien de la démocratie
pour moi c'était important de préserver
notre marque rassis et le bon
fonctionnement de nos deux marques csssa
que la défense très présente et c'est ça
qui doit être préservée dans les détails
le dif est la nouvelle chambre dans
laquelle siègeront les députés en
janvier et plus spacieuse et moderne
mais selon louis plamondon il lui
manquera un petit quelque chose
j'espère qu'on va réussir à transporter
les fantômes de celui là à l'intérieur
pour pouvoir faire qu'on sente le même
esprit parfois de collaboration parfois
d'opposition mais a un mental de
recherche continuelle du bien commun il
confie que son souhait le plus cher
c'est d'y siéger encore quand l'édifice
du centre rouvrira ses portes dans plus
d'une décennie
ici feignent olivier radio canada ottawa